grignotage goûter en cas repas l'estomac
fonctionne h 24 et depuis des siècles la
tentation est encore plus grande
les boulangeries et autres fast food
pullulent et le peu de temps accordé au
déjeuner n'aide pas à une alimentation
variée et équilibrée
alors comment perdre du poids la
nouvelle tendance
le jeune intermittents ont dit qu'on va
partager la journée en deux parties une
partie dimanche
kim a duré huit heures et pendant 16
heures en imaginant pratiquement on
avait demandé à partir de 21h n'empêche
pas le matin et on reprend les
nourritures à partir de 12h 13h au début
il va perdre beaucoup de poids après il
va stabiliser il va changer son
métabolisme et quand il chante son
métabolisme
il est plus difficile à quoi de pouvoir
pensionnat pernaut pau 16 heures de
pause alimentaires selon des chercheurs
américains
c'est une méthode minceur efficace qui
entraîne une perte de masse graf et
préserver au mieux les muscles à
condition de privilégier une
alimentation saine en quelques semaines
les fest est visible j'ai déjà perdu
cinq sets qu'il aurait quand même dans
six mois et bien au niveau du ventre on
dégonfle
quand même ça dégonfle quand même le
corps et on se sent bien la langue mais
il faut le faire
c'est assez dur quoi le jeune serait
bénéfique sur le système immunitaire
il serait même selon des chercheurs
américains plus efficace que de compter
ses calories pour garantir une perte de
masse grasse